con gritos de vida ucrania no a la
guerra y en contra de putin al que
tildan de terroristas decenas de
ucranianos están reunidos desde horas de
la mañana frente a la embajada de la
federación rusa en madrid una embajada
que permanece cerrada y con fuerte
presencia policial
quieren que rusia dé la cara y les
expliqué por qué han comenzado una
incursión militar y por qué están
matando a sus hijos el ambiente es de
preocupación con constantes llamadas de
familiares que van actualizando la
situación en el país de europa del este
en cuanto a reacciones oficiales es
unánime el rechazo a las acciones de
rusia tras un consejo de seguridad
nacional presidido por el rey de españa
el presidente del gobierno pedro sánchez
mandó un mensaje claro a putin que ponga
fin de inmediato a las hostilidades y
que revoque la proclamación unilateral
de independencia de daniels y lugansk
sánchez afirmó que esta agresión
injustificada a la legalidad
internacional no debe quedar impune y
que españa sedes vivirá por restablecer
la paz insistió
la respuesta del país será coordinada
con sus aliados de la unión europea y la
otan